hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the great
work ok so apparently someone told me
that that was supposed to be a
distraction for the monsters and I
wasn't supposed to jump right on top of
them
that was the stupid thing to do but
since I'm already here I might as well
so now that I'm down here in the
monsters are hey you think I'm stupid
I'm just got almost no health potions
left so I might be boned in that regard
but I now have light okay I think I ran
down here I believe so I ran down here
screaming like a little baby I ran in
here screaming like a little baby I ran
over this way screaming like a little
baby um yeah yeah this all seems
familiar
through tear-stained eyes I think I I
think I went this way okay so let's not
waste oil I've been giving up of a
fairly high amount compared to the
amount of oil I've received before so
let's not waste it this way I think I
remember running through here screaming
like a little baby and yeah hello
did you do that baby tell me if you did
you would protect me right probably not
okay I've ran in here screaming like a
little baby and that place is lungs so
which way did I go where did I go I
don't think I went this way so let's
explore over yonder into the dark depths
of madness oh this looks good
no no moveable paintings is this is a
room of nothingness balderdash I refuse
to believe it even though I run away
there must be a common unifying Hall
[Music]
what the hell was that something
exploded up no my darling oh no
something happened to her
oh maybe maybe I well maybe I won't know
okay that's locked in then this kind of
looks familiar but I mean how did I been
through here before yeah I definitely
have been so where am I I'm just
wandering in circles wandering in
circles with nowhere to go what the hell
happened here
something happened here I'm not gonna
keep wasting oil I'm gonna live without
it for a little bit just in case I
needed the help
wait a minute this is where I ran
through oh okay
ah that's the route I was supposed to
take and I did the wrong way ah ah
okay so let's backtrack this way until
we get to the place where I was supposed
to go okay yeah this is this is the way
I was supposed to push down the statue
and then run down here while the
Munsters were distracted and then I go
in the opposite hall and I got to find
that door that was a push door or a pull
door instead of a push door oh man it's
just hard because I don't remember going
through all of this when I was running
in a bit of a panic wait what's down
here I gotta check this before I go on
hello hello is anybody here yes No ah
into this cellar all other sources
exhausted Johan turned to the few
Mithraic manuals that had survived the
ages he didn't expect to find much their
legendary wisdom was rivaled by their
disdain in keeping records that seems
counterintuitive okay what's this it's
actually break down here and possibly
kept paregoric
ha it's on behind here some some secret
no secret something hidden under there's
got to be a secret here can't hide from
me ah fine I'll see what here hello no
something under you nothing waste of my
time it won't budge whoa budge what do
you mean it won't budge what am I
supposed to do Vasek whoa stronger than
I thought ah York's nothing No it won't
budge well what am I supposed to do
about that okay
looking around I saw that stuff I moved
it and I would have thought that I would
have seen something but apparently not
okay
yeah that's kind of weird well anyway I
guess I'll come back to the cellar later
any these why was I wasting my oil right
there I have no idea okay that won't
budge definitely will not budge all
right I guess it's going back now into
the for yay gotta find that door that
was a ball and not a push and it was to
the right I know it was I know these
things great work is before all things
the creation of man by himself that is
to say the full entire conquest over
faculties in future hartleb felt like a
cheater and then to the stone the music
got a bit more dramatic not sure why
hide that statue get back up there hey
what the hell yeah the music definitely
shifted I like it when it does that
there's always get the failure it's
about to do something that I'm not gonna
like okay ran through all these rooms
let me try to get back in my own mind
right behind me
oh Jesus
we're wrong with you [ __ ] off it's not
fair I was so close I was right there I
was right there that rube Duff freaking
room uh yeah I gotta be more careful
sneak like little Barbie it's not gonna
matter
[Music]
[Applause]
don't slap those ah okay
you didn't hear anything let's go like
this and in this corner and hide okay I
can't get out it's gone oh come on why
are you driving being a rubber ball ah
come on ah can't see me through this
chair blocking your field of view can't
see me I can't believe this is working
house is weird ah ah [ __ ] you not good
okay the first one to push the second
wanna pull got closing door give me some
time just give me some time to survive
buddy 30 December sixties God John found
his body two weeks ago locked in the
cellar of his home the shadow forgiven
me but not him over the devil years many
my course bonnets have been to ending
with yo.hannes death I think it is time
for us to go our separate ways for the
past 10 years I've kept most of my
activities secret from the circle and
I'm sure they must resent me for it I
pray that they forgive me because I was
only trying to protect them
bla bla bla other contacts evasive
perhaps a circle is not dead yet though
I wonder why I'm being exclude from so
as I know from Samuel
was not helping me in this situation ow
[ __ ] I'm doomed okay that door is locked
that door is locked that wasn't a pole I
told you trained locked oh man those
baloney I can't go anywhere these
a-holes a-holes holes of a wait a minute
is that door just like two that all know
if that's just if that's just a loop I'm
gonna be so pissed but there are other
rooms here that I need to explore over
this way namely
that monster spawns down the hallway
that I haven't been yet so I'm gonna try
to get around and why I don't know I
just need to get around him he's there
okay just calmly like this calmly and
collectively Oh hahaha
oh he's going that way heats up stupid
oh he's so stupid oh he's so do ba'd aha
aha of all the universes creation not
exceed the human kind in complexity
science could not understand how
molecules and chemical interactions
great the capacity of abstract thought
in a mad mad nation even the glory of
the stars could not compare that's a bit
egotistical don't you think now we're
pretty great Humanity is pretty awesome
way better than stupid stars okay anyway
doesn't look like anything's here this
where Samuel is just making progress
really slow progress I got chased around
way too long there I'm sorry folks but
still that was pretty awesome god this
custom story is amazing oh man okay just
crank up the volume a bit just a little
bit da okay
no jump scares this there's custom
stories too good for jump scares it's
all about the atmosphere and suddenly
I'm Isaac Clark okay ah this is Samuels
ah this is where he got bashed open
Charles I'm sorry it had to turn out
this way I wish I could explain
everything to you but my time is running
out the monsters are after our shards
the ones fused to your body and the one
I have been protecting in this mansion I
had thought it's safe here but I have
let my guard down the monsters will
never stop hunting these shards but you
cannot let them fall into their hands
please protect them and closed is my
address of the personal library in
London if you have managed to purify
aqua Risha you will need it when you get
there study my materials well within
them as a means to fight the enemy I'm
sorry I cannot assist you personally but
I do not think my barricade will last
another minute
avoid the golem with the glowing chest
it is an unimaginable danger huh please
hurry to my library so there may be hope
yet of escaping this conspiracy I hope
we meet again
Samuel hartleb okay so that's the heart
lift guy didn't know that because if we
were referring to him as Samuel
okay so there's apparently I'm pretty
close to meeting the new monster I'm
thinking I may just continue this
episode until I do find him since that's
what you guys are all looking out for
that's not a good thing that's now
getting a lot down and dumb I need more
than that I have been using up my supply
rather copiously oh god is that the new
monster that's you chase music what is
that music
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I need to go far why was it right
there where did Samuel go Samuel are you
the monster are you really the monster
you really the monster aren't you you're
really the monster oh no oh oh oh I
think reminded me of the rake I've never
played a game with an accurate
representation of the drawing to the
rake that I've seen but that might have
been the closest thing I've ever seen oh
my god I need to get some sanity back
come on stop with the blurred vision I
just gave you some sanity potions okay
so I'm guessing I go back and get the
hell out of here
what the hell happened here what
happened here do I need to go this way
cellar I thought it was just a cellar
oh boy okay alright so you guys saw the
new monster
Oh see me okay this must be the new area
so I'm out of time for now so thank you
all so much for watching click there and
it takes us for more videos it I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
whoa
[Music]
you